[Music]  in today's eight on your side with goods  and services costing more than they have  in 40 years you'll no doubt notice an  increase in your car insurance premiums  inflation hitting every sector rod  griffin senior director of consumer  education at experian explains why  things like you know the cost to replace  a bumper if you wreck your car is going  to go up and that means insurance rates  are going to go up because they have to  cover those costs  griffin says you can look at ways to  save money by shopping around and  comparing your insurance rates apples to  apples experian has a tool that does the  work for you at experian dot com forward  slash safe the company has partnered  with the top insurance carriers in the  country all you have to do provide a  copy of your current insurance policy  experian will do the comparison with  more than 40 different carriers griffin  says they save the average person about  900 dollars a year